it's getting close to Halloween and I
was out hiking in one of our local state
parks with my oldest child cat just this
last weekend and we got to reminiscing
about something that we had done much
much earlier back when cat was just a
child in the early 2000s and not here in
the Milwaukee or out in southeastern
Wisconsin area but rather in
Northwestern Indiana similarly out in
the countryside but a somewhat different
terrain than what we have here and I
asked cat do you remember the pumpkin
farm that we used to go to for a long
time it was just me and Cat and then uh
the the next child the one of two uh was
born Maddie and we began taking Maddie
along with us as well as an little baby
and then as a toddler and this pumpkin
farm was something you know quite unique
to the area and so I'm going to tell you
a little bit about it and why we had so
much fun why it became something that we
did over and over and over again and
form some great memories about so that's
the Sadler stories is going to focus on
so when I say that we lived in
Northwestern Indiana we lived in Rose
Lawn which is you know a little town on
the county line in between Newton and
Jasper counties these are two very rural
counties lots of farming going on you
know not a lot of uh people living out
there it's in you know around 17 to 18
to
19,000 in those those counties and um
there's a lot of space a lot of you know
Forest a lot of uh metaland actually
that entire area used to be more or less
underwater it was the the grand Kaki
Marsh until it was finally drained it
actually had massive biodiversity
according to Old stories and accounts
about it and so it got turned into an
area where there's a lot of uh you know
scrub Oak and Autumn Olive and other
kinds of things growing in the area and
it tends to be rather flat with you know
a few Hills here and there and County
Roads basically crisscross it north
south east west and so we would go
driving a lot you know we would often
have to go places and because I I like
the area and I thought it was kind of
nice to take a scenic route we wouldn't
always take the most direct way and so
we would drive around and see what there
was to see and around you know
October probably early
October this was you know cat would have
been probably three or four years old at
the time we saw signs for this pumpkin
farm and you know they're big signs and
they had kind of cool stuff on them and
and I was like we we should go check it
out so we drove you know following the
signs down the county road and then
there's a driveway that you have to turn
off on and a gravel road that you you go
up a ways and there it was there was a
place to go park your your
vehicles and there was lots of stuff
going on um sometimes I'll tell you you
know I don't know if it was the very
first time that we were there but other
times there would be like school
buses and uh you know other things
carrying kids you know Cub Scouts would
go there Girl Scouts would go there
school trips would would you know make a
field trip to go there because this had
been around for quite a while my
relatives who lived in the area knew
about it and um it had kind of a a good
reputation so we would go there and the
first thing that you do is you to you
know go in and get yourself some tickets
for the various things and there was uh
you know place to go to to the booth to
get tickets for the various attractions
let's call them and there was always a
fire going as well you know a campfire
in a fireplace surrounded by stones with
plenty of places where you could sit so
there was you know nice Smoky uh smell
in the air and there were you know
scarecrows and uh other things that were
supposed to be kind of spooky and scary
you know placed in in different spots
and you know that time of year it starts
to get cold in the mornings and at night
and even sometimes during the day it can
be a little overcast but for the most
part it's still you know pretty decent
weather so you wear your flannels you're
not wearing a t-shirt anymore and you
dress up a little bit but you don't have
to bundle up as if it's winter or even
late fall at this point although as you
get closer to Halloween there was always
the chance of it getting cold enough to
to snow so we'd go and you know we would
uh see the people and after a while cat
and I and then cat and Maddie and I went
there so often that they they all get
got to know us they you know they
thought the kids were cute and uh they
you know they knew me as the dad who
would take uh the kid or kids to this
place and we would do it without any
groups right so it was always us on our
own sometimes we'd tag along with some
other kids if there was a small enough
group and Cat would often kind of
outgoing explain what was going on to
the kids who were there for the first
time so I think the people who lived and
worked there because it was a family Run
Place kind of got a kick out of the kids
and so you know we would do things like
like well what should we do first so one
of the attractions that cat loved and
Maddie really loved was a train now it
wasn't the kind of train that you might
expect it was a big
lawnmower and there were 50 gallon drums
that had you know they had been placed
on their side and they had um you know
let's call it a passenger seat cut out
of them and so you would you would sit
in the drum and there was like a cushion
for you to sit on and they were all
yolked together in this long train and
there was actually like a path going
through the woods and a few scary things
along the ways you know a couple Hills
to go up and stuff like that so it was
kind of like a combination of a a train
and a a
really easy roller coaster a roller
coaster that's not going to Loop to Loop
or anything like that and the kids just
loved it and not just my kids but kids
in in general and it was run by a guy
who had put on you know an engineer's
cap and he had like his his uh um what
do they call that sear sucker uh
overalls that train people have and he
had a big whistle that he would blow
that sounded like a train whistle and
off they would go with this this
lawnmower pulling this long uh chain of
um cars I guess they they were I mean
they had little wheels on the bottom and
uh it was quite a production so that was
one of the big things that they would
do and then there were like trails that
you could walk
along and they would go down into an
area where there was a haunted house
that you could go into and you could buy
tickets for that as well um after a
while they just kind of slip us tickets
you know give us extra ones you go in
the haunted house and it wasn't huge or
anything
but it was It was kind of fun but what
the kids really lik the most I think was
as we would walk along the trails there
were various places where animals were
living especially goats there were a
number of goats that were in um
different areas and they would come
right up and you could you could
purchase you know food to give them so
it was kind of like a petting zoo and
you know the goats are kind of spooky
looking with their weird little eyes
that you if you've ever seen goats you
know what I'm talking about and they you
know they have different colors and some
of them some of them were wandering
around some of them were uh behind a
fence and and you know they're all
pretty tame there were chickens there
were rabbits there were other kinds of
animals couple dogs and lots of stray
cats as well and so you know that was
kind of fun too um towards the like end
of the season they would have haunted
hay rides that you could go on there
that you you know cost a little bit more
but it was quite a lot of fun and they
would get local high school kids to
dress up and come out with you know like
a chainsaw no no blade on it of course
but you know scaring you like
Leatherface and things like that so you
know I would actually take the kids
because the kids you know they liked
getting scared and they weren't they
weren't easy to scare either so that was
you know compared to other children uh
that was something that I got a kick out
of and I think the the park people did
as well so we would do these sorts of
things and then you know they sometimes
have bobbing for apples and other
traditional Halloween sort of stuff I
think they also had like costume
contests but we never actually got
around to doing that we would do our
trick or-treating uh in other places in
the subdivisions that were near us or in
the trailer park and things like that
and then they would also sell um
sandwiches and um hot chocolate and hot
cider and popcorn and a few other things
as well so we would spend our time you
know like maybe an hour going around the
park and doing various things and riding
on the train and then we'd get ourselves
something to eat taffy apples too they
had and so we'd get ourselves all set up
and then we'd kind of like take a little
break and quite often the grandmother
would be sitting by the fire you know
she would uh just kind of hang out and
shoot the breeze with us and she she
always got a kick out of cat and Maddie
so um you know we' we'd have a fun time
with that and and we got to know these
people over time now
unfortunately um we're talking about the
early 2000s and if you know your
American history you know that um 2007
2008 we had what was called the
financial
meltdown and that had to do with like
housing but also all sorts of other
things within the economy many people
lost their jobs and what we found is you
know the pumpkin patch place did stay
open but it was one of those things that
was kind of dependent on you know you
could call it tourist money if if if you
want but it wasn't all tourists it was
all sorts of other local people and it
wound up being one of those luxuries
that I think a lot of people as budgets
got Tighter and people lost their jobs
just wasn't uh wasn't in the cards
anymore
and you know we went back a couple times
I also mention one other thing too I
mean it was a pumpkin farm so you would
they had like a huge selection of
pumpkins and Gore
cat would always get her get a white
pumpkin uh you know I would usually get
a nice big one we'd carve the stuff and
so they were you know growing these on
their their farm and probably also
buying some from local farmers all of
that started getting more and more
shrunken there would be less
available and after a while you could
tell that they were kind of struggling
there were fewer people people there
there wasn't as much to to eat and
drink um you know there was talk about
whether they would be able to open it
the the following year and eventually it
did close up in fact uh we went back one
time uh you know probably I want to say
in the the 2010s and it was it was
completely gone there was no more I mean
the place was there but there wasn't any
of the stuff that we had become
accustomed to seeing there and you know
I asked my relatives about that and they
said yeah I think it it it closed down
um unfortunate you know one of many many
casualties of the financial crisis that
we we went through but for a long time
that was um something that we would look
forward to every year going back to the
pumpkin farm and doing all of these
things together and we would manag you
know in an average October to get three
or four visits in and to really enjoy
ourselves and you know it was cool that
now CAD is
21 um they still remember it fondly
there's a lot of things that my kids
don't remember that we did in the past
but that is one of the things that stuck
with them perhaps because of the
repetition perhaps because it made a big
impression on them and uh you know was
it like the best or some unique pumpkin
farm and Halloween Place probably not I
mean there's tons of these places all
over but it was special for us and you
know it was maybe about a 15minute drive
across country roads as the trees were
turning as the grass was becoming Brown
and red and you know changing into to
different colors so it was always
connected with a time and space and part
of our way of living together back then
so that's that's my story you might have
similar places that you got to go to um
and hopefully you had as much fun there
as we did at this pumpkin
farm
that